bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord votre
avis sur les mesures qui ont été
annoncées hier par jean castex et le
ministre de la santé libérant
je regrette
une
pression trop longues dont laquelle se
fondit lui et finalement les les mesures
qui devaient être dit et je trouve ont
plus que n'a pas dit un mot aux patients
de l'hôpital est sûr qu est ce qu elles
et leurs perspectives d'avenir pas des
réponses uniquement économique mais
qu'est ce qu'on propose pour l'hôpital
pour le monde de la santé pour pouvoir
continuer à assurer les soins des
français et je ne vois pas entre les
dents les mesures qui ont été annoncées
hier hop une qui permettent dans les
quinze jours avoir un contrôle de la
vague épidémique qui nous affecte et qui
met en difficulté la population et
l'ensemble du système de santé en france
donc
notre inertie est trop forte
ça veut dire que
demander que les choses soient mises en
place à partir de début janvier
ça veut dire que dans le meilleur des
cas il y aurait un impact à la mi
janvier
c'est c'est trop tard c'est une période
dessine la période hivernale tous les
ans c'est déjà comme ça avec la vie non
plus et le risque de la grippe le virus
lorsque la danse elle circule c'est très
compliqué puisque vous parlez des
hôpitaux et des moyens nécessaires
ajustements pour lutter contre l
épidémie quelle est la situation
actuellement est ce que l'arrivée
du variant qui est déjà présent sur le
territoire omicron
risque justement de faire en sorte que
les hôpitaux soient saturés
les hôpitaux sont déjà en difficulté
il faut pas imaginer lorsqu'on bis qui
lie à ses occupations
hospitalisés
3300 qui sont en réanimation que ça nous
reste encore une marge de manoeuvre aux
de progression pour continuer à prendre
ces lignes sont habituellement toujours
occupée il tourne tout le temps il y a
tout le temps des passants donc
forcément il y en a quelques-uns que
nous avons pu décaler déprogrammé et en
plus à ces périodes hivernales et
pendant les vacances et rillettes de
vacances la demande des plus importantes
et il ya des lits fermés faute de
personnel donc notre capacité de
réaction d'adaptabilité et diminuer nos
personnels sont peu prisés vous voyez
bien que ce soit les médecins en ville
où que ce soit les infirmiers en ville
où l hôtel tout le monde traduits
c'était puisse ou non cette laisse une
il faut absolument un discours qui donne
du sens au travail et ça on n'a pas
entendu hier c'est un peu comme aura
mixte mais croyez moi que ma
préoccupation n'est pas les conditions
de travail des soignants ma
préoccupation c'est que les soignants
nous continuerons à assurer l'accueil
des français la prise en charge de
qualité la sécurité et la qualité des
soins pour chaque français lorsqu'ils se
présentent au système de santé et que
ceux ci risquent de ne pas être
garanties si nous laissons continuer
c'était bibémi on nous rassure en disant
que c'est un plateau non non ce n'est
pas un clatot il y à une épidémie qui
augmente encore avec le variant au
micron est il une épidémie avec un
plateau très élevé dans certaines
régions et continuer à augmenter avec le
variant delta donc c'est la perspective
n'est pas bonne et j'aurais mis quelque
chose que vous donne une lumière à
l'horizon sur lequel nous sommes
rassurés
le discours hier
gouvernement s'est concentrée sur la
vaccination le pass sanitaire et à la
réduction aussi du délai pour la douce
de rappel à trois mois dès mardi les
dessus votre à lire
ici convaincu de l'importance de la
vaccination il est évident que la
vaccination reste un élément central
dans la stratégie
de vote pour faire face aux risques de
cette pandémie mais elle n'est pas toute
seule la stratégie vaccinale
c'est un des éléments un des éléments
importants mais on a d'autres soucis que
nous devons également utilisé pour
protéger la santé de nos compatriotes et
ce sens et autres outils dont on n'a pas
assez parlé et de toute façon le post
vaccinales c'est à partir de la mi
janvier où tout le temps de passer les
lois des textes et toute la rigueur et
la lourdeur administrative pour pondre
une disposition comme celle ci c'est de
dire on ne peut pas imaginer que c'est
ça qui va résoudre le problème nous
avons besoin d'aimer sans quitter
aujourd'hui commence à donner du sens et
l'argument qui consiste à dire les
français ne sont pas prêts à accepter ça
moi je trouve que c'est infantile et les
français les français à chaque fois
qu'il a fallu prendre des décisions
courageuses
parce qu'elle était dans l'intérêt de la
plupart des français ils ont toujours
été d'accord ils ont toujours soutenu
c'est de ces
dispositions c'est un peu le engagés
nous sommes un peuple courageux je ne
peux pas accepter qu'on dise que les
français ils vont être timoré ou
craintifs à l'idée d'avoir à faire des
sacrifices à jour à l'année souligne un
jour de fête s'est vraiment que vous
passez pour résumer à elle répété
animaux c'est l'absence d'une stratégie
globale de la part du gouvernement pour
lutter contre l'épidémie
en
tout cas lire la présentation ne
permettait pas de voir clairement quelle
est la stratégie globale
quelles sont les mesures qu'on donne au
moins un système de santé en difficulté
quelles sont les mesures
d'accompagnement à l'école puisqu'on va
pas la faire mais je pense que c'est
raisonnable mais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire en contrepartie ok on va laisser
les restaurateurs et la restauration
ouverte et on nous dit que l'on va on va
pas laisser que les gens aillent obama
un cap et nous prendrons bien ça ne me
paraît pas d'une efficacité remarquable
en tout cas il n'y a aucun élément
scientifique à évaluer ce type de
mesures donc nicolas elle répété à lino
face à aunis colossal de circulation du
virus et donc il faudrait des mesures
beaucoup plus ferme beaucoup plus engagé
beaucoup plus contraignante eu
probablement mais je suis certain que
les français accepteraient si on leur
explique quel est le sens de ces mesures
et comment tous aussi s'organisent pour
défendre
l'accès aux soins et français bien sûr
et pour défendre le système économique
notre système économique aujourd'hui est
directement menacé par l'augmentation
des arrêts de travail et d d d d arrêt
de travail c'est pas parce qu'on les
malades hawks ou parce qu'on est à une
personne contact
c'est ça qui met aujourd'hui en
difficulté au moins bien qu'il n'y a pas
d'opposition drôle up sanitaires et
l'économique les deux se rejoignent et
il faut travailler pour éviter la
circulation virale et c'est ça qui
permettra de continuer à faire tourner
notre économie il n'y a plus
d'opposition entre l'eau sanitaire et
l'économique merci beaucoup à vous
aimeriez casalino chef des urgences à
l'hôpital bichat à paris bercy avant